oh
hamon
cours
donc
oh
donc pour la mi-juin 2011
je rentre un message qu'il faut
contourner djibo concerne l'être quand
et pour cette île 38 quelques jours
vidé ma valise et j'entends que pour lui
mais sa ferme
les jeunes et tous les africains
mes soucis
le serbe déjà que
on sait déjà que j'ai habité ici
comment ça
mais pas que
dans ma valise de l'électronique
de quoi faire un mini studio
d'enregistrement du fromage en quantité
du chocolat et ma trousse de toilette
avant de partir je suis allé aux bords
de la sarine avec franz on a discuté
layon goze en fait
bon ben ça se passait bien là ces vingt
dernières années tout grammont coup tout
comme avec ma femme et la famille mais
bon personne comprend rien en tout cas
là ça marche plus vraiment très fort ok
je m'en vais pour les indes
j'arrive sur place un bénarès mon
premier et mon premier feeling j'en ai
tellement ras-le-bol des deux je me suis
dit je lui puis tout m'acheter une
caisse de whisky pour un peu qu'est ce
qui se passe avec les vertus de l'opium
dans le coin puis je pensais six mois
vont pas si relativement vite
ça devrait être réglé facilement mais il
se trouve qu'il s'est passé exactement
la baisse en dix jours un show je suis
dans la vie à bénarès à fond la caisse
j'ai trouvé un site av magnifique
j'ai un gourou extraordinaire et je
prends des cours à raison de trois fois
par semaine ce qui est quand même une
cadence à si intense si affreux dans le
truc je joue toute la journée et par la
position
voilà au bout de très vite j'ai des
problèmes de circulation du sang ge ge
et ont plus aucune sensation sur mon
gros orteil et ouest commence gentiment
à flipper j'en parle à mon gourou lui
une petite ou tranquillement au il faut
faire du yoga pas de problème
pas mon style bon ok toute façon j'ai
pas trop le choix je une école de yoga à
20 mètres de là donc jb je fais du yoga
sans trop y croire mais être non très
étonnant mon problème son va tout de
suite je viens même accro à ce truc là
je vais même plus haut cours je préfère
faire ça directement dans ma chambre je
me réveille le matin je bois un verre
d'eau et voilà je fais une heure dit aux
gars ça me convient tout à fait bien
quand j'ai le blues ça m'arrive de temps
en temps je vais me promener dans la rue
mais mon problème est réglé en un
claquement de doigts rien qu'à voir la
situation des gens ici et des conditions
de vie et c'était un coin donc tout va
bien sûr la foulée jean louis gafner mon
ami et partenaire pour les concerts me
téléphone unique écoute je n'ai pas si
on a incité d'accord je viens de trouver
away avec plaisir écoute juste pour que
tu saches je peux mettre mes appareils
de projection ça tient dans ma valise
donc on peut organiser quelques concerts
ça me ferait plaisir
ah ouais bonne idée ok j'en parle à mes
amis indiens on organise le concert sur
place alors là quand je parle de ça mon
gourou nous regardent avec des grands
yeux
il m'a dit tu sais d'habitude les élèves
ils prennent six ans de cours avant de
faire des concerts aux villes de ça fait
seulement quatre mois que tu es là j'ai
dit ouais mais je vais jouer des
compositions personnelles
ah ok c'est très bien à ce moment là
personne n'a aucune idée de mes
expérimentations électroniques sur le
site à je suis la règle classique
traditionnelle musique indienne
acoustique pur je dis à personne je
montre à personne je garde ça pour moi
mon gourou samba aux états unis il a
courte son voyage de quelques jours pour
arriver à boire au moins un seul concert
sur les dieux après le concert vient de
trouver une écoute j'ai entendu toutes
les notes que tu as joué que ce qu'il
allait faire avec ça
sur la folie dit écoute je t'invite à
venir jouer dans ma maison j'ai écrit
sur mon petit carnet je pense que c'est
la première fois que dans le temple de
la musique classique indienne à ménard
et ce même donc vous parle du sacré là
il ya un bus qui va se pointer avec un
site art collection de [ __ ] et envoyer
des sons à l'envers à l'endroit
ouais j'ai marqué ça sur mon carnet
junior un grand succès à ce concert
c'était fantastique chercher déplore un
trophée du prix l'on dise raymond
couraud à faire manger pour toute
l'assistance qui était là c'était
impressionnant
génial deux jours plus tard je prenais
l'avion rentrer en suisse
bon là c'est moins drôle on est le 22
décembre j'arrive à fribourg tout le
monde est blanc pressé c'est l'effet
d'où là là quelle histoire
mais les jours passent tranquillement et
avec ma femme ses coups de théâtre
incroyable on discute on arrive à se
mettre d'accord on annule le divorce
extraordinaire les choses apparemment
faux super bien en août 2012 la famille
réunie sous un nouveau toit et tout se
passe super bien
décembre 2012 je publie un livre à
propos de ce séjour au nahd et je fais
deux concerts qui sont successfull on va
dire il ya du monde tout le monde est
content je ne comprends rien comment ça
se passe mais on mai 2013
rien ne va plus je quitte la famille
nous décidons divorcer je me retrouve
chez jean-louis mon pote
et là quand je me réveille au matin
franchement j'ai pas le courage de faire
du yoga
là j'arrive plus pratiqué le truc non je
vais me rouler une cigarette plus tôt
avec trois papiers puis boire du café
plutôt que de boire du thé au gingembre
là franchement la bombe atomique à péter
schep plus où j'en suis je suis capable
de plus rien heureusement quelques pages
réalisé assez vite je suis capable de
plus rien ne se décide de rien faire
ça sent la situation c'est cool dans le
salon à jean-louis à des dvd
ça parle de méditation c'est des cours
pour des méthodes assez efficace de
méditation on va déjà que je fous rien
je peux au moins faire une heure par
jour
regardez ces dvd parfait les mois
passent
je reçois la connaissance jamais ma
pratique et je pratique tous les jours
yoka sida méditation le tetris met en
place tout gentiment je fais rien tu
vois tout seul
le divorce est prononcé les affaires
sont réglés je trouve un appartement je
commence à perdre de trois concerts
gagner un peu d'argent
une discussion avec france au mois de
mars 2014 mais un terme à notre
collaboration avec les young gods mon
super bilan plus de familles plus de
femmes plus dur gold parfait la vie est
belle quoi hockey dans tout ça mon père
qui est malade sa santé se dégrade
j'arrive pas à rester chez moi jouer du
sitar on pense en quelques minutes de
voiture là ma mère s'épuise son chemin
ok je mets la musique de côté je décide
de m'occuper de mes parents c'est ce que
je fais et charif quand même organisé
une empathie à raison de quelques heures
par jour seulement
j'organise des concerts en suisse à
l'étranger en france au portugal au boom
festival une tournée en inde ou au népal
une suivante l'année d'après enfin
j'arrive à plus ou moins manager
quelques dix quinze concerts sur l'année
et plus les choses avancent plus je
m'occupe de mes parents et je mets la
musique de côté c'est là que je
rencontre youth qui est un producteur de
renommée internationale j'ai rendez vous
dans trois semaines à l'autre vous mixez
mon album
ces tissus tard du sitar comme personne
n'a jamais entendu mon nom pu c'est tout
nouveau tout frais magnifique
dans la folle et on va faire des
concerts super intéressant ici cet été -
juillet à l'île de gau ça va être
franchement génial un concert pour le
festival de la terre ou la scène est
purement alimentée par la cellule
solaire ou alimentation eau solaire
c'est des expérimentations de gens ont
résumé après tout ça je peux vous dire
j'ai la mostra pêche on va dire c'est
comme si j'avais 20 ans en fait 23 ans
exactement quand j'avais vingt trois ans
exactement
j'ai envoyé péter tout le monde tout ça
pour faire la musique tous les jours
c'est ce que j'ai fait c'était génial il
y avait trois frères tout était là
aujourd'hui je me retrouve exactement
dans la même situation avec en plus du
yoga de la méditation qui m'aident à
accéder mon coeur c'est lui qui a raison
c'est lui qui sait je pense que avec la
confiance la bonne volonté
beaucoup de confiance une confiance
pratiquement aveugle on écoute son coeur
et je pense que là ces conditions tous
les raids sont réalisables
merci